هذه ارقام ومعلومات تختصر المباراه
التاريخيه للمغرب في مواجهه اسبانيا وطبعا
اولها ان المغرب هو اول منتخب عربي يحضر
في الدوري بعد النهائي بتاريخ كاس العالم
المغرب اول منتخب عربيا خد ركلات الترجيح
بتاريخ كاس العالم وهو اول منتخب عربي
يحافظ على نظافه الشباكه في ثلاث مباريات
مندليه بنسخه واحده وفي الارقام القياسيه
ايضا المغرب اول منتخب عربي يقضي اربع
مباريات من دون خساره في مونديال واحد اما
اسبانيا المونديال بركلات الترجيح المره
الثانيه على التوالي وهي تخسر برجله
الترجيح للمره الرابعه في تاريخها وللاسف
ركله الترجيح الاسبانيه الاولى صدمت
بالعارضه
لكان حارس المنتخب المغربي ياسين بونو اول
حارس في التاريخ يتصدى لثلاث ركلات ترجيح
متتاليه بتاريخ كاس العالم وهي بالمناسبه
خساره المؤسفه في عالم الارقام